what's going on guys this is rob and we
are covering batman the imposter which
something i need to point out ahead of
time this is part of dc's black label
those you guys don't know what that
means black label is basically dc's
equivalent of marvel max so you're going
to see a lot of cussing and you're going
to see a lot of violence
just be aware of that having said that
this story is amazing oh my god it's so
good and here's the thing i firmly
believe that the batman in this is
basically robert pattinson's batman and
there's no better person to draw this
than andrea sorrentino max and tomlin
just
he just absolutely kills it in terms of
the writing but andrea sorrentino's art
oh my god okay those of you guys who
don't know who this is there was an
amazing moment right the way that when
when andre sorentino won me over it was
actually during old man logan kind of
inside here and then we'll jump into
this bear with me here there was a point
where wolverine where old man logan goes
into like a berserker rage when he's
fighting like lady death strike and i
think the ravagers it was during the
border town storyline and the way it was
drawn was just amazing god i love andrea
sorentino art so here's the thing right
god this story is so good you guys are
gonna be begging me for more of this
once we finish right because we're doing
the first part right we're gonna we're
gonna do this over the course of the
week as background videos um and then do
our regular videos as well uh so so yeah
you guys are gonna be dying for more of
this so what this does is this initially
opens up with batman basically showing
up in the the apartment or the office of
leslie thompkins now those of you guys
who don't know who that is leslie
tompkins is basically kind of like this
night nurse-esque character she is a
person that batman usually brings people
to whenever they need some kind of
treatment but they have to stay off the
radar uh and it's also one of those
things where he goes there himself now
she's as much a person that helps people
escape terrible situations as she is
like an actual doctor but basically she
is or at least here she's essentially a
therapist and so one of the things
that's kind of nuts is she says like
like the batman is bruce wayne and he's
bleeding to death on my floor in a few
minutes the emts will come the police
too he'll be in arkham the second they
stop the bleeding it might actually be
the best thing for him so why can't i
make the call and so you get this kind
of like rehash here right this sort of
rehash about the the nature of him where
it's basically like i can't imagine how
much pain brought him to this place
parents murdered right in front of him
brutally grotesquely when he was sent to
me i gave him a laundry list of
diagnoses acute anxiety obsessive
compulsive disorder possibly on the
spectrum the ptsd of course for all of
his behaviors it was his rage that
frightened me the most the rage that
drove his guardian away the rage that
i'm sure was his compass guiding him
when he disappeared for six years i told
him back then if he didn't learn how to
control that rage it would get him
killed it scares me how right i was
right so this is this is something i
understand here leslie tompkins and
bruce wayne have a very close
relationship it's not romantic that's
something that i want to establish here
they're not lovers it's one of those
things where in a lot of ways she was
the person bruce would go to when he
seemingly couldn't go to anybody else
over the years in dc comics leslie
tompkins has just kind of been depicted
as i wouldn't necessarily call it like
uh like a mother figure but like a close
aunt you know what i mean like that kind
of a thing and so it's one of those
where like he kind of refers to her as
leslie and she's like no no dr tomkins
right like i'm a sucker for formalities
and it's kind of an interesting thing
because it's a sort of ease into this
conversation right where it's like you
know i brought you back you know welcome
back by the way you know like literally
i saved your life bruce wayne uh you
know i'm not calling the police and
telling them that bruce wayne is batman
i mean can we keep on going or is that
like is that is that going to do right
is that going to be fun now one of the
things that's also kind of put off here
and this is what's interesting is that
while the relationship between leslie
and bruce in the main dc universe is
very close there almost seems to be a
kind of edginess here right where it's
kind of like i don't know because
remember the black label stories take
place in different realities right
they're basically what-if stories in dc
comics right they're not really
incontinuity per se they're just stories
that exist out there it's not to say
that elements of the black label won't
become a mainstay in dc comics
especially if they just prove to be
exceedingly popular like for example if
this relationship as it's depicted here
between leslie tompkins and bruce wayne
turns out to just be a ridiculously
popular interaction between the two you
could easily see dc just kind of
experimenting with that and depending on
how popular it is with people who read
the main batman stories it would become
a mainstay right so it's just one of
those things that they usually end up
doing with with comics now there's also
a bit of a sarcastic banter right where
bruce wayne's like where's my clothes
and she's like when you say clothes you
mean the bat suit that you wear to
assault people in the street every night
right you know and he's like where are
they you know and that's one of the
things is because at that point that's
when he wants to like leave right get
back out and do his thing the response
of leslie is no that's not going to
happen sit down right tell me what's
happening tonight because you know and
when he asked like why would i do that
she says because if you don't you know i
will call the cops and i will get you
the psychiatric care that you need i
will have you i will have you like
committed to arkham asylum and that's
the thing i mean i guess she couldn't
really do it per se but literally
informing the authorities that bruce
wayne is the man they're looking for who
dresses as a bat in the middle of the
night and pummels criminals it wouldn't
be too hard to make a compelling case
that this guy's basically insane it's
kind of an on running thing with batman
that like the fan base has kind of just
been contending with for decades and
decades right is batman secretly just an
insane person you know and so she says
like if this happens right if i have you
committed i will tell the world that
bruce wayne is batman i will spill your
identity out to the world so sit down
and that's one of the things just so
great about this right the interaction
in terms of like her kind of vigor right
the fact that like leslie tompkins is a
pull no punches won't put up with your
kind of person she's always been that
way that's not new to the black label
like leslie tom because it's always been
the person where like you don't want to
piss her off like that kind of person
not only because of the fact that like
she would probably beat the crap out of
you but she knows people who knows
people you know what i mean like will we
tie the poor soul who breaks into the
home of leslie tompkins and like steals
something or something like that because
not only do you have to contend with her
because she'll probably shoot at you
then you got to deal with batman and
then you got to deal with a bad family
they will all come after you and so what
we get here and this is where the the
black label element really kicks in
right where dc just kind of throws out
the normal rules of batman and it's just
we get this super dark and super gritty
version of him is that he basically
explains like it was a relatively quiet
night right and then he basically ended
up you know coming up on a burglary that
was going on where basically these guys
were like robbing a robbing a liquor
store now one of the things that happens
of course batman beat up a couple of the
guys and then in the midst of all this
one of them ends up shooting a guy or
shooting the uh the cashier at the
liquor store right so essentially it's
almost kind of like batman made a
mistake or he didn't predict it and now
this is the big difference between black
label and the main dc comics because if
this was like batman as is being written
by joshua williamson right now what it
would just be batman being batman right
and batman would save the guy from being
shot you know things would have just
happened in such a way to where only the
bad guys would be injured and that would
basically be it no no no whether it's a
miscalculation or simply just the nature
of how uh the black label is being
handled and and matson the way that
matson tomlin is writing this that
basically one of the guys gets his shot
off and actually ends up killing the
liquor store cashier right and that's
one of the things where the guy's like i
don't want to die like i really like
dude's like begging for his life and
batman's like no no just keep pressure
on it at that point one of the guys ends
up taking this dude's kid hostage or it
looks like this dude's kid i don't know
who this kid is but it looks like his
kid and batman goes for like one of his
little batarangs which is not really a
it doesn't look like a batarang per se
this is why i say it looks like robert
pattinson because this batman looks like
he's relatively new to all of this right
like he's still really kind of getting
his bearings and starting out and as i
understand it because i haven't seen the
movie yet so i'm not spoiling anything
but as i understand it robert
pattinson's batman is supposed to be
like one or two years into being batman
but given like how everything looks in
the trailer and how primitive and how he
seems to lack all the really advanced
technology that we're used to with with
traditional batman it looks like he's
basically relatively new on the scene
either that or he's broke like it's one
of those two things right like batman he
got no money
which is actually what's going on in dc
comics right now but the thing is of
course he goes to throw his batarang and
he basically misses and that's when the
guy's like my turn fires off a few shots
and actually one of them catches batman
so he doesn't really have the
bulletproof armor that we're
traditionally used to and that's one of
the things is because at that point
where he goes kind of crashing through a
window the assumption is they managed to
get him right they managed to shoot him
uh so it seems like at least on some
level he might have bulletproof armor
just not covering his entire body the
way he normally does but once these guys
basically take off they basically hijack
a car and then they shoot the driver
right so they kill the driver on the
spot so we're just i mean this is just
this is what i'm saying man black label
it's just violent and it's amazing
they kill the driver and then jack the
car and basically bail that's what one
of them realizes batman's still coming
after them on his motorcycle right at
that point batman catches up and
literally overtakes one of the guys
snaps his arm right like once he gets
him out of the vehicle snaps his arm but
then batman ends up getting stabbed and
so at that point that's when he just
kind of you know seems to leave one of
the guys there and then just basically
walks away and so at that point what it
looks like here is batman kills the guy
like literally just slashes him across
the throat right so like batman kills
this dude and then basically leaves
right and then heads for the office of
or at least for the home of leslie
tompkins and that's the thing right she
kind of says like so did you come here
to die you know once once we get back to
him telling the story or at least back
with uh leslie tompkins you know she she
asked like did you come here to die or
did you come here for help and
ultimately he says like either one would
have suited me just fine now this is a
big statement to make i'm not familiar
with like the the dsm-5 the ins and outs
of it but as i understand of course
that's the book that's basically used
for diagnoses by the by a psychologist
but as i understand it a person that
doesn't care whether they live or die is
an extreme danger to themselves and
others because in the end they don't
really seem to care how their actions
affect other people because the value of
self-preservation seems to be the most
significant value that any human being
has but once an individual has no value
for their own self-preservation how
could you possibly believe they would
they would have any value for anybody
else's preservation and so that's a
major concern that goes on and so that's
when she asked like how did this happen
to you right how did you go from like a
little kid right the son of the waynes
to becoming this person who is seemingly
so lost and so disconnected from not
just their humanity but from the human
race as a whole he says this was not
some unfortunate side effect this was a
choice it was a vow and she's like what
the hell are you talking about and he
doesn't really give an answer right off
the bat instead he basically gives a
response and says i went to the ends of
the earth to learn to control the
monster not to purge the fear or the
pain but to become it and that's when
she says like bruce i say this as a
psychotherapist you sound insane what
bruce wayne is really saying here this
is an important thing over the course of
our lives as people we will encounter a
myriad of circumstances that will
seemingly make us feel like it's turning
our lives upside down right sometimes
those circumstances are extreme and they
can irrevocably change the way in which
we see the world what bruce wayne did
here is that unlike most of us who will
basically find a way to cope with the
pain or who will find a way to to find
some sort of positivity in the pain or
if we choose to use that pain as a
motivator we may end up using it
momentarily right so you know like you
you use it as a it's like a motivation
to work out or to improve your life what
bruce wayne did is he let it overtake
him he let it become the defining
attribute of himself instead of saying i
will use the pain of my parents death as
a motivator to make gotham city a better
place his response was i will use the
pain of my parents death to become that
pain to become that fear to become that
anguish to become that grief so i can
take all those horrible feelings and
those negative emotions and i can
instill those in any person out there
anywhere who would ever even think of
committing a crime who would ever even
think of having those thoughts thought
up in the first place right like they
will feel my pain in the most extreme
this is a big differentiation between
like the batman that we're traditionally
used to the batman in the main dc comics
uses fear and i guess depending on who's
writing the story he can become that
fear and he's done some pretty shady
things but having like the no kill rule
is the thing that kind of separates him
from becoming the very thing that he
wants to instill in other people and so
him becoming this extremely dark version
of himself where you would probably look
at this and say there's no way that he
can be effective this way in fact it's
the opposite one of the things he says
like like leslie basically says like you
need psychological help right you're
putting yourself and hundreds of other
people at risk his response is you've
helped enough and that's when she says
like you're a goddamn bruce wayne right
like if you want to fight crime in
gotham start a sort of [ __ ]
foundation right run for mayor run for
president and then when he leaves when
he goes to leave he's like where are you
going and she basically tells him like
if you walk out that door i'm calling
the cops if you want to test me go ahead
like if you if you really want to test
me bruce wayne test me and watch what
happens you'll be shot or locked up in
arkham asylum within six hours so we can
play this game if you want to but i
promise you bruce wayne it will not be a
game that you win it will be a game you
lose because in the end despite all your
vaunted abilities and all that kind of
stuff you're just a guy and all it would
take is a lot of bullets shooting at you
at one time to bring your life to an end
and it doesn't matter how much
bulletproof armor you have on or where
you're wearing it right so it's one of
those things it's kind of nuts she says
like like one of the things she says
here is like i see right through you
bruce wayne like unless you can convince
me otherwise i'm calling the cops or you
will have to kill me but that's not what
you do because then you'd basically be
like them and so when he when he's like
you know what is it that you want she
said explain it to me and his answer
here is because i'm making a difference
he says last week gotham had its first
night with zero violent crimes in 54
years which is kind of weird because the
question you have to ask here is has
bruce wayne been batman for 54 years
that's really kind of weird what really
is being said here is that gotham has
basically been a violent place for the
last 54 years
because when i initially read that i was
like wait a minute are they saying he's
been no that's ridiculous one he doesn't
look 54. if if this batman is 54 years
old well hell's bells point me in the
direction of the fountain of youth man
because that guy found it right i mean
it exists you know it's it's that thing
but the reality is basically gotham has
just been an exceedingly violent place
but since he's become batman for however
long it's been for the first time in 54
years it had a non-violent night and he
says that didn't happen because of the
cops it's not because of the mayor or
the district attorney it's not because
gotham suddenly grew a conscience it's
because of me it's because of what i've
been doing and her response where she
doesn't really seem to have a response
to it she said she simply says that may
be but that doesn't mean that you're not
a danger to yourself and she says you
can grit your teeth and threaten me all
you want to i'm not really worried about
you bruce wayne and then she simply says
sign this and she basically gives him a
document that is essentially a patient
doctor confidentiality agreement that
until such a time that he makes a
statement that says like he intends to
cause you know the death of a person or
to inflict unnecessary harm on someone
else or unless she's subpoenaed by a
court and has to testify she can't tell
anybody anything about what their
conversations are right they're legally
protected again there are exceptions to
that right so you can't go to your
therapist and say hey so i plan on
killing that person over there and
here's how i'm going to do it and here's
when i'm going to do it and here's how
i'm going to get away with it you can't
say that because if you do they are
going to call the cops right there are
there are exceptions to conversations
that you have with your therapist where
they're actually not only will they tell
the cops they're actually legally
obligated to right so again there's
there's things that go on that go on in
there i mean if they didn't do that and
you actually went made good on your
threat and it was discovered that you
did tell your therapist and they told
nobody they would lose their license and
probably be arrested i don't know what
the legal ramifications are for that
specifically but those are probably two
of the most obvious but that's the thing
you know when she says when she says
like i can't break confidentiality
unless i think there's an imminent
threat to your life or somebody else's
he says but there is leslie there always
will be but in the end it kind of seems
to be this unwritten thing where it's
not it's not really her meeting with
bruce wayne about whether or not he's
going to harm another person that's just
kind of an inevitable thing and it's
what he does and there is merit to the
argument of him saying i am making
gotham city a better place right i mean
its first non-violent night like no
violent crimes in 54 years that kind of
says something that's not really an
arguable point and that's why she says
every morning at dawn you will come to
this office and we will talk about what
you're doing we will help you together
if you don't show up i call the police
and so his response is okay it's not
really about stopping bruce wayne from
being batman and basically beating the
hell out of criminals and possibly even
killing a few it's about trying to
trying to basically fix him right trying
to find out what it was that led him
down this path of becoming just so
hopeless not really about society but
about himself and then trying to find a
way to fix that so with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
let me know if you guys want to see more
man because i got it i mean this is only
just the part where he's in her office
like there it's it's just it's a
phenomenal story it's a ridiculously
phenomenal story i mean there's a lot of
stuff that goes on right like like
especially when like the headlines start
hitting that like batman kills it's kind
of nuts but like there's just some
ridiculously amazing moments in this and
there's one point where he looks exactly
like robert pattinson uh in fact i'll
show i'll show it to you right here
right it's literally this one panel
right here tell me that's not robert
pattinson it's the spitting image of the
guy but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace
you